sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ich bin Oberleitner von der
Presseabteilung des
Verteidigungsministeriums ich werde sie
durch die heutige Pressekonferenz führen
im ersten Teil werden
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
Brigitte
ur und Oscar-Preisträger Stefan osnitzki
und ORF Regisseur Kurt Pongratz
das Programm des Bundesheeres zum
Nationalfeiertag
2022 vorstellen
im Anschluss davon besteht die
Möglichkeit Fragen zu stellen
und zuletzt stehen Frau Bundesministerin
für Landesverteidigung Claudia Danner
der Militärkommandant
Frau Ministerin ich bitte sie um ihre
Worte danke vielen Dank sehr geehrter
Herr
Militärkommandant sehr geehrter Herr
rosowitzky Herr Pongratz sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der Medien ein Wort das
sehr oft verwendet worden ist seit dem
24 februar ist das der Zeitenwende und
ich denke es ist sehr sehr treffend weil
der Beginn des Angriffskrieges Putins
auf die Ukraine ohne Zweifel einen
Einschnitt in die europäische in die
österreichische Sicherheitspolitik
dargestellt hat das macht uns tagtäglich
schockiert und betroffen dass der Krieg
nach Europa zurückgekehrt ist und Friede
keine Selbstverständlichkeit mehr ist
daraus haben wir alle Lehren zu ziehen
spätestens seit dem Beginn des Krieges
wir sehen dass die konventionelle
Kriegsführung nach wie vor Realität ist
das heißt für uns insbesondere als
Bundesheer das die militärische
Landesverteidigung an Bedeutung gewonnen
hat die ja die Kernaufgabe des
österreichischen Bundesheeres ist was
wir aber auch sehen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ist das auch andere Mittel
wie Cyber-Attacken Desinformation
wirtschaftliche Druckmittel ebenfalls zu
Teilen der Kriegsführung geworden sind
das heißt wir müssen uns sehr breit
aufstellen als österreichisches
Bundesheer zur Verteidigung unseres
Landes wie breit wir uns aufstellen
müssen das hat uns nicht zuletzt auch
die Pandemie gezeigt als unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten am höchsten
Zeitpunkt 8000 im Einsatz waren im Kampf
gegen die Pandemie wir alle nicht nur
das Bundesheer auch die Wirtschaft alle
Organisationen der Republik Österreich
müssen uns vorbereiten nicht Pandemie
auf regionale Kriege auf Konflikte auch
auf Naturkatastrophen sehr oft denkt man
sich es sind Dinge wahr geworden die vor
ein paar Jahren noch tatsächlich als
undenkbar
gegolten haben das ist bittere Realität
geworden oder um vieles wahrscheinlicher
und daher ist es unglaublich wichtig
dass nach jahrzehntelangen Durststrecken
es mit dem österreichischen Bundesheer
wieder bergauf geht bergauf was das
Budget anbelangt wenn sie an die 16
Milliarden Euro denken die uns in den
nächsten vier Jahren zur Verfügung
stehen bergauf aber auch geht wenn sie
an das Vertrauen denken die das den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gegenüber
entgegengebracht wird und das gestiegen
ist allein vom vorigen Jahr auf das
heurige um 20 Prozent und daher ist es
wirklich eine ganz große Freude heute
hier mit unseren Partnern zu stehen wenn
wir erstmals nach den Einschränkungen
der letzten beiden Jahre auch wieder vor
Ort hier mitten Team zeigen können der
österreichischen Bevölkerung zeigen
können was wir alles können was die
Antworten die vielfältigen Antworten auf
die aktuellen
Bedrohungen im Inland und im Ausland
sind wir werden aber so wie in den
letzten paar Jahren auch all denjenigen
die keine Möglichkeit haben hier diese
Leistungs- und informationsschau unsere
series zu besuchen die Möglichkeit geben
dieses multimedial zu tun auf
Nationalfeiertag
22.at kann man sich über die
vielfältigen Leistungen des Bundesheeres
informieren und ich freue mich wirklich
sehr und es ist eine ganz besondere Ehre
das seit dem Jahr 2020 für den
Nationalfeiertag gestaltete spezielle
Kurzfilme über die Kernthemen unserer
leistungschau aber auch filmische
Porträts der milit Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die heuer ganz besonders in
Zentrum stehen gezeigt werden und dass
Kurzfilme sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
bereits zum zweiten Mal von niemand
anderem als dem Regisseur und Oskar
Preisträger Stefan roswitzki gestaltet
werden das ist wirklich eine ganz
besondere Freude an dieser Stelle namens
aller Soldatinnen und Soldaten und
Bediensteten des Bundesheeres herzlichen
Dank dafür wir freuen uns alle schon
darauf ihre Filme dann am
Nationalfeiertag zu sehen es gibt aber
auch auf der homepage-möglichkeiten
Nationalfeiertag 22.at in die eine oder
andere soldatische Rolle auch zu
schlüpfen es wird verschiedenste
Panoramen gehen wo man in die Cockpit
seines Eurofighters eines Kampfpanzers
eines Black Hawk
Hubschraubers einsteigen kann und so
zahlreiche Einblicke bekommt ja und ich
freue mich auch wieder dass all dies
insbesondere auch die protokollarischen
Höhepunkte des Nationalfeiertages im
Fernsehen zu sehen sein werden ich freue
mich über die bereits tatsächlich sehr
bewährte Zusammenarbeit mit dem ORF der
alle diese protokollarischen Höhepunkte
aber selbstverständlich auch die
Leistungs- und informationsschau
übertragen wird Herr Pongratz an dieser
Stelle auch vielen vielen Dank dafür und
ich glaube wir freuen uns alle schon auf
ihre Live-Übertragungen am 26 oktober in
aller Kürze noch im Mittelpunkt steht
heuer ganz besonders die Miliz die wir
als besonderen Bestandteil des
Bundesheeres hervorheben wollen wir
wollen auf die gemeinsamen
ausbildungsübungen die notwendigen auf
die gemeinsame Arbeitsweise auch
hinweisen das wird man hier sehen am
Heldenplatz online sehen und auch im
Fernsehen mit Sicherheit spüren wir
wollen aber auch etwas zeigen auf dass
wir Österreicher glaube ich besonders
stolz sein können weil unser Bundesheer
nicht nur
Sicherheit im Inland sichert sondern
dies mit einem heutigen Tag 821
Soldatinnen Soldaten in 14
Auslandsmissionen tut immer mit dem Ziel
dass die dortigen Konflikte nicht in
Österreich wirksam werden den
betroffenen Menschen geholfen wird vor
Ort geholfen wird das tun wir seit über
60 Jahren höchst anerkannt und leisten
damit einen wirklich wichtigen Beitrag
für den Frieden in der Welt wenn Sie ein
voriges Jahr denken da was notwendig
dass direkt von hier vom Heldenplatz
unsere Hubschrauber Richtung Hirschwang
starten mussten einer der größten
Waldbrände den wir jemals hatten in
Österreich dann sieht man auch dass wir
auch bei Elementarereignissen wie diesen
bei Bränden bei Naturkatastrophen
hochwasserhilfen schneeräumungen Suche
nach Lawinenopfern immer wieder im
Einsatz sind und sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren auch das wird die Leistungs- und
informationsschau zeigen
was mir gerade in diesen Tagen und
Wochen wichtig ist und die
Vorbereitungen haben selbstverständlich
lange davor begonnen wir werden uns auch
am heurigen Nationalfeiertag mit der
Thematik Extremismus jeglicher Art
beschäftigen und den besondere
Aufmerksamkeit widmen sie wissen dass
wir als Bundesheer gemeinsam mit unserem
Kooperationspartner dem Mauthausen
Memorial KZ-Gedenkstätte Mauthausen
einen Informationsstand betreiben wir
haben ja eine langjährige Partnerschaft
und Zusammenarbeit und wir werden diese
präsentieren alle Kooperationen alle
Aktivitäten zur Stärkung der
demokratischen Identität die Kooperation
mit dem Mauthausen Memorial ist unser
Beitrag der Beitrag des Bundesheeres
europäischen und nationalen Strategie
gegen Antisemitismus Rassismus und
totaler totalerismus denn eines an
dieser Stelle auch noch einmal klar
festgehalten Extremismus hat im
österreichischen Bundesheer keinen Platz
und ich werde es nicht zulassen dass der
eine oder andere Einzelfall die
großartigen Leistungen und das Vertrauen
in das Bundesheer auf irgendeine Art und
Weise zerstört sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren freuen Sie sich auf unsere
umfassende Leistungsschau die zeigt wie
vielfältiger die Aufgaben des
Bundesheeres sind wie einsatzbereit
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind und
an dieser Stelle freue mich wirklich
schon sehr wenn wir auch so um die
Mittagszeit dann am 24 Oktober hier
zusammenkommen werden um dann die für
den für den Nationalfeiertag
einfliegenden hubschrauberpilotinnen und
Piloten die Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
einfachenden Panzerfahrzeuge hier am
Heldenplatz begrüßen zu dürfen
dankeschön
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren als
Militärkommandant von Wien darf ich sie
aus organisatorischer Sicht auf unsere
heutige Veranstaltung
hinweisen und darüber im Detail
informieren gestatten Sie mir zu Beginn
gleich zu sagen ich bin persönlich auch
wirklich froh dass wir hier am
Heldenplatz wieder eine groß Angelobung
haben dass wir unsere traditionelle
Informations- und Leistungsschau auch
wieder präsentieren können sozusagen wie
früher
quasi Bundesheer zum Anfassen
diese Veranstaltung ist dann damit auch
wieder die größte Veranstaltung des
Bundesheeres im heutigen Jahr und die
zweitgrößte Veranstaltung österreichweit
das vielfältige Aufgabenspektrum des
Bundesheeres und die Fähigkeiten zum
Schutz Österreichs präsentieren wir in
der Wiener Innenstadt am drei Plätzen
wir sind hier am Heldenplatz wir sind
beim Burgtheater am Josef Meinrad Platz
und wir sind am Hof
der Heldenplatz hier sozusagen unsere
Hauptbühne der präsentieren wir von der
militärischen Landesverteidigung
beginnend über die bereits
angesprochenen Miliz bis zur Karriere
beim her
beim Burgtheater gibt es die
Katastrophenhilfe des Bundesheeres zu
sehen und beim Platz am Hof den
Auslandseinsatz des Bundesheeres
an militärisch und Großgerät finden sie
heuer beispielsweise drei Hubschrauber
also Black 3 und oh 58 es werden wieder
fast alle gepanzerten und geschützten
Fahrzeuge des Bundesheeres zu sehen sein
die wir als eingeführt haben also
Leopard Ulan
es wird dann grossgerät zum Beispiel
auch das aufklärungs- und
zielzuweisungsradar Flamingo zu sehen
sein oder das abc-abwehrfahrzeug Mammut
der Flugsimulator weil ich schon beim
Gerät bin der wird sicherlich wieder
großes Interesse bringen insbesondere
bei der Jugend
der Bereich der Mittelstraße hier am
Heldenplatz also hinter ihnen wird
wieder für Vorführungen genutzt werden
diese werden unmittelbar nach der
Angelobung starten also nach dem
ausmarschieren der Ehrenformation machen
wir dem ausmarschieren der angelobten
Soldaten haben wir hier Präsentationen
auf der Mittelstraße die dritte
ehebrigade aus dem Auto und wird
gemeinsam mit der milizenszenario
darstellen wo es um den gemeinsamen
Einsatz von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen und
Infanterie geht es wird den
sportvorführung geben ein militärisches
Tattoo von der Militärmusik
Niederösterreich ein Show existierender
die Landung von Fallschirmspringen auf
der Mittelstraße werden dann diese
Vorführungen kurz vor 13 Uhr abschließen
es gibt dann aber auch im Anschluss den
ganzen Nachmittag auch weitere
Vorführungen
traditionell präsentieren sich zum
Nationalfeiertag auch zivile Stellen mit
uns die Frau Bundesminister hat das hat
das Mauthausen mobile bereits
angesprochen es ist auch das
Justizministerium bei uns
die Sanitätsversorgung der Veranstaltung
wird wieder in bewährter Weise von den
4-4 Wien übernommen die Führung haben
wieder die Johanniter
am 26 findet ja auch das
sicherheitsweester Stadt Wien am
Rathausplatz statt wir sind auch dort
wieder präsent weil es eben ein sehr
gutes Miteinander zwischen Bundesheer
und Stadt in Wien gibt
so viel zum Überblick nun ganz konkret
zu den einzelnen Tagen wie schaut das
Programm aus
wie Sie hier sehen können sind wir
mitten im Aufbau wir werden diesen
Aufbau am Montag den 24 abschließen die
Anlandung der Hubschrauber ist gegen
Mittag vorgesehen danach erfolgt das
Eintreffen der mechanisierten Fahrzeuge
hier am Heldenplatz
am Dienstag den 25 gibt es den Tag der
Schulen hier haben wir der Schülerinnen
und Schüler die Gelegenheit sich die
Informations- und Leistungsschau auch im
Rahmen ihres Unterrichtes anzusehen
nun zum Nationalfeiertag selbst
protokollarisch beginnt
internationalfeiertag mit der
grenzenüberlegung durch das Herrn
Bundespräsidenten in weiraum um 9 Uhr
und danach schließt die Graz
Hinterlegung der Bundesregierung um 10
Uhr an
die feierliche Angelobung beginnt hier
am Heldenplatz um 11 Uhr
unmittelbar vor der Angelobung wird ein
Überflug stattfinden von zwei
Eurofightern und einer C130 Hercules
zur Angelobung werden ca 1000 Rekruten
antreten diese Rekruten kommen aus ganz
Österreich aus der wirklich aus allen
Bundesländern und sie werden hier eben
gemeinsam ihr Treuegelöbnis leisten die
stärksten Kontingente der Rekruten
kommen von der Garde aus Wien und vom
Panzergrenadierbataillon 13 aus
Oberösterreich
die bereits angesprochene Informations-
und Leistungsschau die ja an drei
Standorten hier stattfindet beginnt um 9
Uhr
der Rückflug der Hubschrauber wird um
16:30 Uhr
angesetzt sein danach fließen die
gepanzerten Fahrzeuge wieder aus dem
Heldenplatz durch die Stadt hinaus und
offiziell wird die Informations-
ich bin wirklich überzeugt dass wir für
jeden
unserer Zuseherinnen und Zuseher etwas
dabei haben für jung und alt
und ich lade Sie daher ein möglichst
zahlreich zur Informations- und
Leistungsschau zu kommen die
Wettervorhersage für den 26 schaut gut
aus ich gehe von einem angenehmen
Herbstwetter aus so wie heute mit
weniger Wind das heißt ideal für den
Ausflug hier um sich von der
Leistungsbereitschaft des Bundesheeres
und von der Einsatzfähigkeit der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu überzeugen
vielen Dank
ja liebe Frau Minister ich war dieses
Jahr wieder eingeladen ein paar Filme zu
machen führte
Nationalfeiertags Übertragung das Thema
dieses Jahr ist Miliz wie schon erwähnt
wurde das sind Porträts von Miliz
Soldaten und Soldaten
das beherrschende Thema war natürlich
gerade
für
Soldaten die aktiv im Dienst sind auch
die Ukraine die die vieles verändert hat
wir waren ja glaube ich alle
haben das mehr oder weniger als
ausgemacht gesehen dass es
konventionelle Kriege in Europa nicht
mehr geben wird das ist allenfalls eine
Atomkrieg gibt wo wir überhaupt Eltern
keine Chance mehr haben und das hat
natürlich gerade für diese Personen
vieles verändert und ich glaube man
wir finden es alle wichtig dass eben der
der Aggressor Russland zumindest teuer
bezahlen muss für diesen Angriffskrieg
kulturell wirtschaftlich aber eben auch
militärisch und ich glaube wenn man die
Opfer der Ukrainer
respektiert und bewundert dann kann man
nicht selber sagen aber uns geht das
alles nichts an und wir sind nicht
bereit
notfalls etwas Ähnliches zu machen bei
den Interviews oder bei den bei den
Gesprächen der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
gibt es natürlich auch ein
gerüttelten Maß an Patriotismus
nationalfeiertagsbedingt aber
dieser Heimatliebe wird definiert über
über
Sozialversicherungen über Wasser Kultur
Meinungsfreiheit und das finde ich ist
dann ein eine Heimatliebe in
Patriotismus hinter dem wir alle stehen
können und ich finde ja sehr dass man
Begriffe wie Heimat und Patriotismus
eben nicht in ganz ganz rechten
überlassen soll sondern dass das gerade
am Nationalfeiertag etwas ist was uns
alle angeht was uns allen wichtig sein
soll danke
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr
geehrter Herr Brigadier lieber Stefan
auch heuer überträgt der ORF wie schon
nach den Jahren 2020 und 2021 wieder
eine der größten Veranstaltungen des
Landes und diesmal aufgrund des großen
Interesses des Vorjahres um eine Stunde
länger
wir haben also vier Stunden Live-Sendung
von 9 Uhr bis 13 Uhr im ORF-Zentrum wird
Frau Rebecca Salzer durch die Sendung
führen und sie wird unterstützt mit der
fachkundigen Expertise von
innenpolitikchef Hans Bürger und General
major Bruno Günther Hofbauer als
live-reporterinnen sind vor Ort Claudia
Tannhauser im Bundeskanzleramt
am Heldenplatz Saskia venenbus und
Andreas maier-buchusch und Klaus
Bruckmann im Parlament beim Tag der
offenen Tür außerdem wird der Fortuna
der Nation Philipp Jellinek mit den
heeressportlerinnen und heeressportlern
das Publikum zum Mitmachen bei fit mit
Philipp animieren das wird wieder da
drüben in der Sport Ecke stattfinden wir
werden als ORF werden wir mit 10 Kameras
diese
Angelobung die grenzwiederlegung die
Angelobung der 1000 Rekruten die
Fallschirmspringer und die Eurofighter
einfahren
wir haben zwei Kräne davon einer in 50
Meter Höhe mehrere Funkkameras und vor
allem wie das dädicams auf Scootern um
den Herrn Bundespräsidenten von der
Hofburg bis zur Grenzen Niederlegung
beim äußeren Burgdorf live zu begleiten
leider wurde die drohnenkamera
die ich mir heuer besonders gewünscht
habe gestrichen aus mehreren Gründen
nicht zuletzt aus finanziellen aber die
Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt vielleicht haben
wir die Chance das nächstes Jahr noch
einmal anzugehen dieses Problem wir
werden aber trotzdem alles daran setzen
wieder spektakuläre Aufnahmen vom
Geschehen am und rund um den Heldenplatz
in die österreichischen Wohnzimmer zu
liefern und daher noch ein paar kurze
Worte zu den sehr zahlen
das Publikumsinteresse für dieses Event
hier Heldenplatz ist enorm normalerweise
hat die Zeitzone zwischen der Zeit im
Bild um 9 Uhr und der Zeit in Bildung 13
Uhr im Schnitt eine Reichweite von
60.000 sehr an und einen Marktanteil von
etwas über zehn Prozent im Vergleich
dazu die Sondersendungen von 2020 und
2020 Corona bedingt ohne Publikum vor
Ort daher auch wirklich sehr viele
Zuschauer
296.000 und eine Marktanteil von
sagenhaften 33 Prozent ein allzeitrekord
der erst
heuer durch das Queen Begräbnis getoppt
wurde
im Jahr 2021 da war sehr gutes
Herbstwetter hatte die Übertragung auch
eine große Reichweite von fast 200.000
Zuschauern und einen Marktanteil von 23
Prozent also weit weit über dem
senderdurchschnitt
auch wir hoffen heuer auf sonniges
Wetter
zumindest am Heldenplatz sonst kann es
in Österreich ruhiger ein bisschen
bedeckt sein zumindest von 9 bis 13 Uhr
und ich bedanke mich auch bei Ihnen Frau
Ministerin und ihr Brigadier für die
gute Zusammenarbeit zwischen Ministerium
und Landesverteidigung das funktioniert
jetzt mittlerweile schon das dritte Jahr
hervorragend vielen Dank
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren es besteht
nun die Möglichkeit Fragen zu stellen
bitte stellen Sie diese laut wir haben
ein bisschen einen Hintergrundgeräusch
naturgemäß durch die Aufbauarbeiten
bitte daher in der ersten Reihe
1 2 ja wir machen es mit Mikrofon bitte
sehr
ja Frau Ministerin der Bundespräsident
hat gestern sehr scharfe Worte gefunden
hat eine Generalsanierung gefordert
fühlen sie sich da als övp-politikerin
angesprochenen was erwarten Sie oder was
soll die Regierung und die ÖVP ihrer
Meinung nach tun um dieses Vertrauen
wiederherzustellen dass der
Bundespräsident beklagt dass es das
nicht mehr gibt ich glaube das sehr
treffende Worte gefunden worden sind
zunächst einmal vom Bundeskanzler und ja
dann auch vom Herrn Bundespräsidenten
ich habe bei einer Veranstaltung des
Kuratoriums für sicheres Österreich
einen sehr
treffen Satz gehört dass Vertrauen das
Lebenselixier am Ende des Tages der
Demokratie ist wie man dieses wieder
zurückgewinnen kann ich gab eines der
besten Beispiele ist das was wir als
Bundesheer was die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten und unsere Zivilbediensteten in
den letzten Jahren erreichen konnten das
heißt helfen dort was notwendig ist
darüber transparent auch zu
kommunizieren und zu informieren dann
denke ich wird man hier auch auf einen
richtigen Weg kommen und ein weiterer
eine weitere Notwendigkeit wird auch
sein sie wissen nicht war sehr viele
Jahre auch in Unternehmen in der
Wirtschaft tätig vielleicht kann man
sich auch dort Anleihen nehmen
insbesondere was allfällige notwendige
Änderungen auch in den gesetzlichen
Grundlagen anbelangt um eben zu einer
Transparenz auch wirklich zu kommen
danke sehr gibt es weitere Fragen
bitte mein Handzeichen ja da hinten ich
komme
wenn sie sagen im Bundesheer geht es
besser auch budgetär was kostet da
Heuriger Nationalfeiertag hier
den Bundesheer geht es tatsächlich
besser weil eine parteipolitisch
übergreifende
einstimmige Antwort gefunden ist gleich
gefunden worden ist gleich nach dem
Beginn des Angriffskrieges und am 25
Februar noch im Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat ein Beschluss getroffen
worden ist dass österreichische
Bundesheer dementsprechend finanziell
auch auszustatten jetzt hat die
budgetrete gegeben jetzt wird es dann
auch den Beschluss im Parlament geben
das heißt wir werden in den nächsten
vier Jahren 16 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung haben es liegt auch im
Parlament ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
vor dass uns Planungssicherheit geben
soll für die nächsten zehn Jahre denn
dieses war in der Vergangenheit immer
eine Herausforderung weil die eine
Ausprägung der Sicherheit vielleicht
ohne Bewertung jetzt gegen die andere
ausgespielt worden ist soziale
Sicherheit gegen militärische Sicherheit
das soll nicht passieren auch nach
dieser Legislaturperiode nicht passieren
und daher hoffe ich dass auch wirklich
alle politischen Parteien dieses Gesetz
beschließen werden die konkreten Zahlen
für den Nationalfeiertag liefere ich
Ihnen so sehr gerne nach und wird meine
Kollegen bitten so diese schon vorliegen
wird mir das dann zu übermitteln ich
sage auf jeden Fall da Werbewert für das
österreichische Bundesheer wird
jedenfalls die Kosten in jeden Fall
übertreffen sie haben vom Herrn Pongratz
gehört wie die Zuschauerzahlen sind wir
dürfen auch eines nicht vergessen wenn
wir über das Budget reden über das was
wir alles zu beschaffen haben nach
entsprechenden Grundlagen Dokumenten
dann brauchen wir auch das Personal dazu
und so eignet sich gerade auch so eine
Leistungsschau den jungen
Österreicherinnen und Österreichern zu
zeigen welch großartige attraktiver
Dienstgeber das Bundesheer dann ist das
heißt das ist nicht nur eine
Leistungsschau sondern auch eine
personalwerbemaßnahme gerade für den so
unabdingbar notwendig notwendigen Teil
auch der Miliz die konkreten Zahlen wie
gesagt reiche ich gleich nach
danke sehr gibt es weitere Fragen
Gott dann sage ich Danke und es besteht
nun im Anschluss die Möglichkeit für
Einzelinterviews hier im Bereich der
Fahrzeuge bitte kommen Sie zu mir und
wir organisieren hier eine geordnete
Interview Reihenfolge danke sehr bitte
die Dame vom ORF